Howdy folks. My last video got a lot
more attention than I was anticipating,
and I have a couple of non-MTG
videos I’m doing research for,
so I figured I may as well put out a quick little
video with a few more thoughts on the EDH format.
Today I want to talk about a few different ways
of orienting a deck in relation to its commander,
and one in particular that
I consider to be underrated.
To start with, let’s talk about a pretty
conventional way of constructing a commander deck.
You find a commander that looks cool, you find
cards that synergize well with said commander,
and then you fill in the gaps with the
other thing the deck needs to succeed.
This is a simple and malleable format,
but there are other options out there.
To talk about those, a useful exercise is
to think about the rules of the commander
format as if you’ve never seen them before.
You’re building a 99 card singleton deck,
something with a naturally high degree of
variability, but you have an ace up your sleeve:
a card that you will always have, every single
game. You could make that card Krenko, Mob Boss
and then play a goblins deck. And that’s a
perfectly valid plan. But something you might
notice about that idea is that the commander and
the deck do basically the same thing—play goblins.
A lot of strong decks will opt to have the
commander do something tangential to the rest of
the deck, tying in with some key cards but broadly
offering something different in nature than the
rest of the deck. However, my favorite form of
this relationship is where the commander does
the exact opposite of the thing that the rest of
the deck is trying to do. Basically you pick out
a commander, and then you build a midrange-y deck
with a glaring weakness solved by that commander.
An example that comes to mind is a Glissa
Sunslayer deck that I built several months back.
The card is a fantastic creature for
three mana—an absurdly effective blocker,
a draw engine, and a source of endless
sadness for decks running enchantments.
The EDHRec page seems to consist mostly of decks
trying to capitalize on removing counters from
your cards, but I instead opted to build a
hardcore battlecruiser deck. The commander’s
flexibility and daunting presence means that I can
fully forget about early game creatures and not
worry as much about draw, instead jamming my deck
to the brim with ramp, removal, and massive cards.
I have a top-notch blocker that’s also a draw
engine every single game, and that lets me use
my deck slots to focus on being the greedy
bitch that I truly want to be deep inside.
Another example of this is a
Liesa deck that I built recently.
When I first saw Liesa, I went “god, that card
could absolutely beat the tar out of people.
All I want in this world is to mercilessly
beat my opponents with that angel.”
So great, my commander is selected. How to build a
deck around it? Well, judging by the EDHRec page,
most people’s answer to that question
is to put it in a lifegain deck. Now,
I don’t hate this approach. Y’know, run a bunch
of cards that gain life and some lifegain synergy,
and a commander that will sap life out of both you
and your opponents. It makes sense, and you could
even argue it sort of fits into my template
here. But that’s not the direction I went.
Instead, I decided to build a deck that’s just
dying, craving for a beater to cut through a stale
boardstate—I built a hatebears deck. I crammed as
many hate bears as I possibly could into the deck,
just truly an upsetting wall of little asshole
guys trying to ruin the day of my poor opponents.
And the deck has ended up working exactly
as intended in a good portion of games—the
cards in the deck chip in damage, prevent damage
coming at me, and generally hinder my opponents in
all sorts of ways, and then Liesa cuts through the
resulting board quagmire to reduce my opponents to
a paste-like homogenate. By design, it’s
a deck with roughly a Liesa-shaped hole,
and I’m able to play Liesa for 5 mana
anytime I want in any game I want.
There’s a lot of room for variation here, but this
gives a decent idea of the basic formula. Running
a commander that covers a particular element of
the deck allows a player to build a deck that puts
that element on the backburner, instead focusing
all its effort on the things that it knows it can
succeed at. This way, you can effectively
just solve the problem you know your deck
will have ahead of time instead of agonizing
over how many deck slots to devote to it.
I certainly don’t like the prospect of figuring
out how to kill my opponents consistently with
a low to mid-budget hatebears deck,
so I just avoided that question.
Midrange is often something that people
look down on for being boring or bland,
but with some creative usage of the rules of
the format you can build a really fun deck
that exists within the midrange realm, and
I think more people should try doing that.